is not fair because if he showed me a
picture for twenty years younger I would
have told you it was Harriet Tubman what
yeah you she's too old to tell hi my
name is Christina hi I'm Mel and today
we're guessing historical figures my
history is so bad you know we both go to
use them well we don't know anything
yeah they are political figures or
anything like that
we're gonna get 12 pictures right now
political figures and we're gonna trying
to guess who they are
okay this is like a founding father for
sure
wait what do you see father look at him
sure yeah that's like a Timothy look
like a Roger to me to what your honors
Timothy Rogers okay that's rude susan b
anthony she um she's a political act
she's an activist good job
wait what is she was she naughty this
work I don't know but she was an exodus
women's rights Mozart that's a girl
Queen Elizabeth for the third oh maybe
maybe the first the first Machado No
okay well meet in the middle
Queen Elizabeth the second hyah near wow
she's thank you Wow who's this okay the
mustache she's German
no I'd sign massage I'm gonna go ahead
agree on Pope Edgar Allan Poe that's a
good guess the most - pretty mysterious
pretty dark like his his work
final answer Edgar Allan Poe you're
right Wow I thought I saw that oh my god
he definitely works for the military
look at his bed I always want to see
he liked his hair yeah it's cute he's
kind of cute
sounds like Captain America yeah he
looks like a Theodore oh he doesn't
anything dear Theodore we don't know the
last name oh we know him what did he
invent the light bulb yeah
Thomas Edison oh that's pretty shocking
yeah he's kind of cute
okay no you know him
ya know I feel like I know him but I
just don't know his name I know he's a
scientist I don't know what his name is
oh wait is it go away Oh Galileo he
looks really from laughs like I wrote a
report oh yeah like tenth grade Robert
Willis was that no no they were 'saying
with Robert okay okay we'll go with your
answer what did you say I forgot oh
jesus knew he was a scientist yeah what
did he do I forgot give you a solution
so you're you Wow I have no idea what
these people look like yeah that's I
don't ever bother but not what they look
like we should know this oh I'm so
embarrassed I feel like you have
something to do with the Underground
Railroad
yeah I don't know I feel like her name
is Rosie Rosie Rosie Parker what no
Harriet Tubman it was enough fair
because if you showed me a picture for
20 years younger I would have told you
it was Harriet Tubman what yeah you
she's too old to tell he did something
with them
Oh Aristotle yeah well no sorry yeah
wait oh look Alice clothes you sounded
so confident because look at what he's
wearing this is oh my god in this
picture join of art yeah no I don't
think so no yeah how do you sure yeah
she fought a great battle and was
murdered in that battle right
she would see you the night you okay oh
I like the earrings okay this is come on
okay what am i doing something is
waiting for us are you kidding me no my
piano
yeah oh you know why are you making me
look bad you don't want to be wrong if
I'm like if I need to say I'll back you
Mozart it's Mozart guys that's it right
yeah I feel like you
yeah it is Shakespeare I know one his
plays we know him can you name one of
his plays Hamlet I feel like an idiot I
was there yeah I feel really stupid for
doing this for like five minutes
Queen Mary oh my god I mean is that
colored she's definitely a queen look at
her she's bawling well I think it's
Queen Mary I was really confident in
which one oh my god
well is this this isn't even a real man
I'm so tired he's Greek to do together
so the final answer Aristotle yeah
Aristotle Julius Caesar this is a bad
picture okay I lost one okay who is it
I don't know I don't look super diggity
I don't want to say this and get it
wrong I don't know my involvement answer
if it's wrong all right okay is this if
it's right I mean is this Jesus look
wrong you know but no one knows what he
looks like so even if we said it was
Jesus we could have been fine yeah he
should be darker than this a lot darker
I hope we did a pretty good job I don't
know how many go right we got a log half
point no this is a full point when I
said it was a big full point this is
happen okay we got three four points
wait three and two halfs out of 12 out
of 12 wherever you got yeah good to be
honest I knew more than I thought I was
I'm proud of myself I feel really stupid
for doing this
I woke up and I was like oh it's folly
Mozart
no got judge good girl press I'm happy
yeah we did a pretty good job good job
Alice bring me a one room honestly we go
to UCLA I think it I don't leave she was
a 4 a 4 out of 12 I think we're gonna
get kicked out 4 out of 4 out of 12 is
pretty good thank you
thank you so much no I'm done I I did
enough a yes I learned enough that I
need this is all I need who is this you
know what let the audience know who this
is I really don't remember
[Music]